hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll this is the Q&A video for idea
number 15 I think was 15 which was a
gauge theory as we said in the video
itself gauge Theory was sort of a
culmination of a summing up a high point
in which were able to bring together the
payoff of talking about quantum field
theories and geometry and topology and
scale and a whole bunch of other things
in an interesting way so the QA video is
going to be actually the things gonna be
an important and a good one I mean the
questions and on the blog post and and
the YouTube videos we're extremely on
point them let me put it that way they
were very good questions and in part I
think that's a reflection of the fact
that this is a very rich and rewarding
topic where in the original video I'm
not able to cover everything interesting
that there was to say about it
now there would be an obvious strategy
to do here which would be to have a
separate video on the standard model of
particle physics because the standard
model is the best theory we have for how
the world really works the quantum field
theory world anyway apart from gravity
but I'm not gonna do that I decided not
to do that because the standard model by
itself is not one of the biggest ideas
in the universe it's on the one hand
really really beautiful and certainly
extremely effective in fitting the data
on the other hand it's a concatenation
of a lot of different ideas from a lot
of different angles so basically for
these videos what I'm interested in is
giving you the basic insights on the
ideas themselves the major concepts that
go into building the standard model so
things like renormalization and symmetry
and so forth but for the actual standard
model many of the details are going to
be left aside they're interesting
they're they're well worth studying and
I encourage you to go do that they're
just not what we're about here in this
series so what that means is that I had
the opportunity in this Q&A video to
fill in some of the gaps between the
gauge theory video and the actual
details of the standard model so let's
get to doing that one thing is this
issue of mass in quantum field theory I
said something
the mass of a particle the mass of a
field so we've said before that quantum
fields when you quantize them they look
like a collection of particles so even
though the mass of something is
something we attribute to an object
something that can have a rest frame and
you measure its mass in the rest frame
we often very casually talk about the
mass of a field by which we mean the
parameter which when you quantize it and
when you get a particle out will be the
mass of that particle so but how do you
know if you look at a quantum field
theory what the mass of the particles is
so I said that the mass term comes from
if you have some field I said I think I
did in terms of gamma the photon field
but let's just simplify our lives and
consider a single scalar field okay a
scalar field with just a single real
degree of freedom as we say Phi of X and
T so at every point in space-time
there's a value for Phi it's a real
number the simplest possible field we
can invent so we're so the punchline is
the mass term is the term in the
Lagrangian City for this field which
looks like some parameter times Phi
squared okay and that's what we won't
try to explain a little bit I'm not
gonna be able to explain it fully
because you have to go through the
details of quantizing it and you know
showing that there's a limit in which it
looks like particles again and so we've
done that part so I'm gonna sort of hope
that you just trust me in some of those
details and instead say you know why is
it fighted cubed or something like that
what's so special about Phi squared so
we know that we have the action this is
how we think about the equations of
motion the dynamics of this field
classically and then we'll quantize it
etc and the action is we've done this
million times I'm going to keep doing it
is worth doing the integral of
Lagrangian okay
DT and the Lagrangian is the integral
over space of the Lagrange density and
the garag density is a function of Phi
and derivatives of Phi so of Phi and so
therefore as the way we usually think
about it is the integral d4
so the integral over all space-time were
over some volume of space-time of this
Lagrangian city and what is the
Lagrangian City L well it is the kinetic
energy the kinetic energy density but
I'm not going to bother with those
niceties now usually when we just did
point particles we said cadet ik energy
minus potential energy for a field
there's other kinds of energy that can
come in so we have minus the gradient
energy this is how the field changes
from point to point in space whereas the
kinetic energy is how it changes from
moment to moment in time and then then
you have minus the potential energy and
there's another term which we could have
had just for the point particle which is
fine it's the interaction energy so the
field is going to interact with other
fields and that's going to contribute to
its energy and that's going to
contribute to its equations of motion
okay but let's ignore that for right now
let's just think about fields all by
themselves just a scalar field all by
itself well let's see now look at some
of the details here the kinetic energy
as it turns out is one-half Phi dot
squared Phi dot in fact you know if I
dot is might be notation I may or may
not have used I forget it's the time
derivative of Phi okay D Phi DT squared
so literally how fast the fuel is
changing in time that squared times 1/2
I'm not going to justify this but it
doesn't seem surprising the kinetic
energy for a particle is one-half MV
squared V is the velocity so it's
one-half M DX DT squared for a field
replacing DX DT with D Phi DT does not
seem like a big stretch where did the M
go if you want to know while kind of
absorbed into the definition of v when
we were you late phi 2 particles
gradient energy so it turns out this is
actually a very nice thing we didn't go
into details here but we know exactly
what the gradient energy is going to be
even before we do anything because of
relativity because of special relativity
special relativity says space and time
are on an equal footing so if this is
what the kinetic energy is we instantly
know what the gradient energy is it's
minus 1/2 derivative of Phi with respect
to space squared now I'm just writing
d Phi DX squared it's really D Phi D X
and then squared plus D Phi D Y squared
plus D by D Z squared if you're in three
dimensions but you get the point
it's the rate at which the field is
changing over space squared so what
about the potential will just write V of
Phi okay so this is what we have to work
with so when you write a scalar field
theory the kinetic energy and the
gradient energy basically are fixed
those are universal those are what we
have for every scalar field that's not
always true cosmologists like to mess
with the kinetic term in interesting
ways but we're not gonna do that usually
what you get to play with are the
interactions and the potential those are
those are the things that come into your
definition of what you mean by this
scalar field theory okay so what is the
potential going to be since we're
ignoring the interactions what is V if I
going to be well what you can do is
remember the whole thing that we are the
whole philosophy we're taking towards
these quantum fields is perturbative
that is to say we're imagining you start
with the vacuum state with a state with
no particles the field just sitting
there very very quietly and then you
perturb it a little bit okay you let the
field vibrate very very gently you don't
have to do that you can imagine you know
the feel fluctuating very very wildly
but here on earth you know even in a big
particle accelerator most of space is
just empty there's a few particles most
of the modes of any particular quantum
field theory are in their vacuum state
so this idea that you start with the
vacuum state and then add a few
vibrations is a very good model to what
we actually have in the world okay so
therefore when we do this V if I thing
we can imagine that Phi is small right
if we imagine that Phi equals zero is
the minimum of the potential is the
vacuum State is that is the classical
vacuum state then we can look at small
variations of Phi so you might say that
V of Phi well it's gonna look like I'm
gonna draw a squiggle there so we don't
need to worry about the parameter the
specific numerical coefficients or
anything like that you might say it'll
be you know Phi to the first power plus
Phi to the second power plus Phi to the
third plus Phi to the fourth etc okay
that kind of expansion and these terms
should become less and less interesting
less and less important as time goes on
and the first thing to notice is that in
fact you're not going to have term
proportional to Phi by itself linear in
Phi because if you did that would mean
that the potential via Phi as a function
of Phi what does this look like in
general well that Phi term means that
the the potential is a nonzero slope at
Phi equals zero and then you know goes
on to do whatever it does depending on
what the other terms are but the point
is if that were your potential the field
would just roll down to the minimum okay
so you're not actually at the minimum if
you were at the minimum you can't have a
term proportional to Phi there for if
you're slightly more happy with calculus
the way of saying this is at the minimum
of the potential the derivative the
potential has to vanish so the
coefficient of Phi has to vanish so in
fact let's get rid of all this there you
go
so we have a term proportional to Phi
squared that's the very first thing that
appears and then if I cubed and 5/4 and
so forth now if I cube to 5/4
are different in us in an important way
from Phi squared in a few different ways
for one thing you notice that if you
look at the kinetic term it is Phi and
it's squared right it's their time
derivative Phi squared but it's still
there's one appearance of Phi to the
second power so there's basically two
appearances of Phi in the kinetic term
likewise there are two appearances of
Phi in the gradient term right D Phi DX
squared so this first term Phi squared
in the potential kind of goes along with
those it's the same order of Phi in the
equations and that actually has an
important consequence so let's imagine
that we only have five squared let's
imagine for the moment that let let V of
Phi be something which I'm going to pre
cognitively I'm gonna predict the future
I'm gonna say let's let this be one-half
M squared Phi squared okay let it just
be that okay
nothing else then the whole Lagrangian
City is looks very sort of
nice and similar right 1/2 D Phi D P
squared plus 1/2 D Phi DX squared plus
1/2 oops - I need some minus signs here
minus 1/2 D Phi DX minus 1/2 M squared
Phi squared so if I appears twice in
every single one of these and remember
how we got the equations of motion the
equations of motion come from minimizing
the action you knew that was gonna
happen talking and writing at the same
time it's not my strong suit so by the
way let me let me say this Q a video is
going to get a little more technical
than the regular videos I know you might
think of the regular videos are already
technical but I'm gonna use this Q&A
video and we can let her hair down as an
excuse to get a little bit more into the
weeds here that it's just inevitable so
I'm gonna be writing even more equations
than I usually do so the equations of
motion come from varying or
differentiating sorry the action and
setting that equal to 0 so you're taking
the derivative and that's the derivative
with respect to Phi right that's that's
the idea you change the value of Phi the
trajectory Phi is on the field
configuration of Phi and you ask for
what is the field configuration of Phi
that minimizes or extreme eise's the
action as a function so therefore and
that's gonna lead to equations that you
get is there's some details I'm skipping
here but you get that equation from the
grunge density and so if the Lagrangian
satine which is what goes into what gets
integrated give the action is of order
Phi squared right if it has Phi squared
in the kinetic term the gradient term
and the potential term and that's all it
ever has then the equations of motion
will be of order Phi they will all be
linear in 5 because you're gonna get
them by differentiating I'm not gonna
write down what they are now why we
could write down what they are the
equations of motion for this particular
Lagrangian density work out to be what
are they gonna work out to be
when you take a derivative of something
squared you bring down a two and it's
gonna cancel the one half that's why all
these one halves are there because
you're gonna eventually take the
derivative of them but then you get a
second derivative instead so we're gonna
get d squared by DT squared minus d
squared by DX squared minus M squared
Phi equals zero okay this is the second
derivative this notation d squared Phi
DT is just that's just the derivative
with respect to time of the derivative
the spektr time of Phi okay so this is
the equation of motion for that
Lagrangian City I'm not gonna tell you
why but you could look it up and you
notice that every term has one
appearance of Phi in there these squared
terms here you know this this d squared
that's not Phi squared that's the
derivative that you're taking the
derivative twice but Phi itself in every
single term only appears once okay why
why do we care about that because that
means we can solve it that means this
equation is exactly solvable and in fact
we sort of secretly did solvent by
solvable you know many of the
differential equations in theoretical
physics are complicated Einstein's
equations are horrendously complicated
typical equations for an interacting
quantum field theory horrendously
complicated that's why we invent Fineman
diagrams as a simple calculation 'el
tool that lets us approximate the answer
we're very very happy if we ever find
equations of motion we can solve exactly
right this you can solve exactly so by
solvable I mean we can get exactly what
the answer is and it turns out the
answer can be written you know you can
look at modes of the its a this is this
is a free quantum field if you look at
this equation there's no interactions in
it except for this Phi squared and what
I'm saying what I'm telling you here is
that Phi squared so V of Phi equals
one-half M squared Phi squared is not an
interaction
strictly speaking oops it is it's part
of the free theory so he made a big deal
when we did our original discussions of
quantum field theory about starting with
free fields and then adding interactions
to them and the free fields the reason
why we could do that is because the free
fields had equations of motion that
we're solvable here it is this is the
equation that is exactly solvable and
gets us a free field and basically the
solutions are I'm not going to write
them down because the chances that I get
all the I's correct etcetera are very
small but they're plane waves they're
plane waves with a certain frequency a
certain momentum moving in some
direction okay they're the modes of the
field those are the exact solutions to
this equation and they have a
relationship that the energy really the
energy density but you know what I mean
squared equals M squared plus the
momentum squared where M really is this
okay so this looks just like the energy
equation for a particle and that's not a
that's not a surprise that's not a
coincidence that's actually really what
is going on so that's why I know I'm
skipping steps and asking you to believe
me a lot but that's why Phi squared or
field squared is what gives you the mass
of a field because field squared in the
Lagrangian City corresponds to equations
of motion that are still exactly
solvable so even if you have the kinetic
energy gradient energy plus Phi squared
you can solve them that's what gives you
the equations of motion for the free
field and then you add on to V if I you
know Lambda Phi cubed + ADA v to the
fourth + etc and these will be
interactions once you have those in your
theory you can no longer solve the
equations of motion exactly instead you
use Fineman diagrams and guess what Phi
cube will give rise to fireman diagrams
of
like that five five five five fourth
will give rise to five in diagram to
look like this
Phi Phi Phi Phi etc that's why that is
hopefully convincing you enough of why
it's Phi squared in particular that
gives you the mass term it's part of the
linearized equations it gives you this
relationship between energy momentum
that we're very familiar with from
particle mechanics and it does not count
as an interaction all by itself so we
can think of free fields as either being
massless if there is no Phi squared term
in a potential maybe there's a
higher-order terms but that's okay
or they're massive if they have this
term so you see that this structure here
for the Lagrangian is very very general
because even if even though there will
be in general many other terms in the
Lagrangian you will always start with
these okay you'll start with a kinetic
energy and remember the time energy time
derivative and space derivatives are
related by special relativity so that's
really sort of one thing that's going on
let me always have a Phi squared term
you never have a fight erm because
otherwise you wouldn't be at the bottom
of the potential and these are the two
things you have you have the kinetic
energy and you have the Max those are
the two parts of defining your free
theory okay and that's gonna be true for
everything so not just for scalar fields
when you get to gauge fields when you
get to fermions like the electron or the
quarks it's always going to be field
squared in the Lagrangian that
corresponds to the mass and this
parameter M really is the mass of the
particle okay of the particle once you
know to that particle description now
one of the reasons why I wanted to talk
about this well I should have talked
about it before I mean it is part of
understanding what's going on but also
you've heard that in the standard model
of particle physics masses come from the
Higgs boson and I wanted to explain a
little bit about what that about is
about because number one it's not all
obvious why that is true number two it's
not even true all right I think we
already said that in protons and
neutrons most to the masses come from
QCD come from the strong interactions
coming from the gluon mediated
interactions inside the
tones and neutrons but some of the mass
is the mass of the electron and the
masses of the individual quarks for
example do come from the Higgs boson I
want to explain next I didn't really get
to do it
so think about spontaneous symmetry
breaking again oh I guess one question
Trafford I'm sure it was asked but I
forgot to write it down was why
spontaneous symmetry breaking like what
is what counts as non spontaneous
symmetry breaking the answer is that non
spontaneous symmetry breaking would be
explicit symmetry breaking so if you
simply wrote down a theory in which most
of the terms in the Lagrangian had a
certain symmetry but one didn't so the
theory as a whole just doesn't have that
symmetry that's an explicit symmetry
breaking spontaneous symmetry breaking
is when the theory has the perfect
symmetry but the state the theory is in
typically the vacuum state the theory is
in violates the symmetry okay so like
here on earth this is an analogy this is
not exactly the same thing but here's
the analogy here on earth if I drop the
pen it goes down right there is a
spontaneous breaking of rotation
symmetry if I'm out there in space the
earth is not there if I'm closer to the
true vacuum then every direction seems
exactly the same but here on earth the
existence of this planet below me
spontaneously breaks rotational
invariance it picks out a preferred
direction called down okay so
spontaneous symmetry breaking happens
when the configuration of the fields
breaks the symmetry even though the
theory itself in this equations of
motion is completely invariant so that's
what we have in the standard model of
particle physics and let's pick a very
simple example of an so2 symmetry
remember so2 is just a circle right it's
just one thing it's just rotations and
let's say Phi 1 Phi 2 space okay I'm
throwing it this way because then I'm
gonna draw the potential V of Phi V of
Phi 1 Phi 2 and so2 is just rotations in
Phi 1 Phi 2 space it's topologically and
mathematically equivalent to u1 so if we
called if we defined Phi
capital Phi to be a complex valued field
5 1 and Phi 2 or real valued fields but
we could define capital Phi equals Phi 1
plus I Phi 2 right and then there's be u
1 symmetry e to the I theta phi you just
multiply that's rotating that fine but
we're not going to do that right now
anyway even though that is what we get
in the standard model but we're not
gonna do it for our purposes right now
okay so now we're imagining that we have
a potential V of Phi 1 Phi 2 that
implements spontaneous symmetry breaking
so what that means is that the quadratic
term the Phi squared term will be
negative so what we want is the Mexican
hat potential ok the famous Mexican hat
looks something like this and there is a
brim of the Hat at the bottom here which
is the vacuum manifold the place where
the field will live with zero energy and
to get that long story short you write
something like minus 1/2 mu squared Phi
squared plus lambda phibes I should be
more explicit here because we have two
fields so this is Phi 1 squared plus Phi
2 squared then I got this wrong in the
in the actual video last time but plus
lambda and let's get it right
Phi 1 squared plus Phi 2 squared squared
ok so morally this is five to the fourth
but this is written in such a way that
it is actually invariant under the
symmetry okay and so I wrote mu squared
rather than M squared because this would
be the mass term for these two fields if
the field were living up there right at
the top of its potential where Phi 1
equals 0 and Phi 2 equals 0 but if it
were there it wouldn't just live there
it would roll down to some point down
here on the brim of the Hat and the
vacuum manifold so mu squared here is a
parameter of the potential but it's not
the mass what do you have to do is
expand the field around the place it's
actually living
okay and in fact let me move that dot
let's that's put the dot over here okay
let's imagine that the field is at 5 1
equals 0
fine 2 equals something okay so what you
should get from our previous discussion
is that I don't know if I if I drew the
potential here maybe I didn't even draw
the potential here but after saying that
V squared V is one-half M Squared 5
squared what does that look like it
looks like just a parabola right V and
Phi and so even if there are higher
order terms Phi cube by 4 etc the first
term you're going to notice looking at
tiny deviations from zero is the Phi
squared term okay so that works even
when the potential is more complicated
but you're not at Phi equals 0 you can
re-expand the potential here near the
bottom into Phi squared plus Phi Q plus
5/4 etc you can rewrite it by shifting
and changing variables it's a very easy
thing to do so that will be so the mass
of the actual field is not mu in any
sense it's some combination of mu and
lambda that you get by changing
variables okay you can do that but
that's one thing you can do the other
thing actually draw it this way so
there's basically this thing that the
field can do it can oscillate back and
forth perpendicular to the direct to the
radial direction sorry along the radial
direction is what I should say so away
from Phi 1 equals Phi 2 equals 0 that
kind of oscillation would be a massive
gauge sorry I almost a gauge boson a
massive boson there's no gauge that
you're here yet we're just doing a
global symmetry okay there's a massive
boson corresponding to oscillations that
go up and down in this room of the
Mexican hat by going
radially either inward or outward from
the origin okay it looks locally like
Phi squared is not 0 and in fact it is
if you read if you change variables but
there's another direction you can go you
can also look at oscillations around the
brim of the Hat right hard to draw here
in a very convincing way
but you can look at oscillations that
stay in the vacuum and fold the these
are they're sort of the two
perpendicular directions starting from
this place where you're in the vacuum
manifold that's the value the fieldhands
you can sort of oscillate in two
different directions what you notice is
along the brim of the Hat it will always
be true that the mass is zero because
the mass is the coefficient of Phi
squared and there's no potential along
that brim of the Hat the potential in
that direction and only in that
direction is zero it's flat so this is a
massless boson so if you had just had
both the coefficient of Phi squared and
the coefficient of Phi to the fourth be
positive then you would have the minimum
would be at the center of the potential
because everything will be going up okay
the minimum be at the bottom
both oscillations would be a positive
mass because you'd have curvature of the
potential that was positive in both
directions but because of this
spontaneous symmetry breaking phenomenon
you have one of the directions in the
potential gives you a mass but the other
one is massless and it is always true
because of the symmetry there's always a
direction in field space where the
symmetry relates what happens to what
what happens at one point to what
happens to another point you notice that
the brim of the Hat every point is
related to every other point by doing an
so2 transformation by rotating around in
field space in that way and because it
is a symmetry nothing can change from
one point to another and therefore the
potential cannot change from one point
to another and therefore the potential
is flat and therefore the mass is zero
so that's a theorem that is called
Goldstone's theorem
although Goldstone definitely came up
with the theorem that the idea predates
them a little bit too Yoshihiro Nambu so
these are often called Nambu Goldstone
bosons these bosons that are in the flat
Direction Goldstone's theorem says that
spontaneous symmetry breaking which I
will now spontaneously breaking for
global symmetries so this is not yet a
gauge symmetry this is just two fields
which I universally rotate everywhere
always leads to massless bosons this was
a big worry when people invented this
this is like the sixties and people are
thinking that Nambu and and Goldstone
and others because they liked the idea
of symmetries they had noticed Nambu
especially was a pioneer for
understanding symmetry breaking
spontaneous symmetry breaking but then
there's a theorem that comes along and
says when there's symmetry breaking
there is a massless particle I think
about massless particles is they're easy
to make right there they don't cost any
energy to make them that was another
question that was asked you know why
doesn't it cost energy to make massless
particles when I say it doesn't cost any
energy what I means is what I mean is it
takes arbitrarily small amounts of
energy if you have a mass there's a
minimum energy that you need to make
equals mc-squared to create that
particle if you have a mass less
particle for any fixed momentum of a
wave or a particle in that field still
has energy but since the momentum can go
to zero the energy it takes also goes to
zero so there's no lower bound on what
the energy is so we don't seagulls don't
bosons in the real world we see
approximate Goldstone boson there's a
whole discourse about pseudo Nambu
Goldstone bosons PNG bees for symmetries
that are broken explicitly as well as
spontaneously but this this was sort of
this line of reasoning was thought to be
bad news for fans of spontaneous
symmetry breaking since we don't see any
Coldstone bosons okay well it turns out
I've been emphasizing that this is for
global symmetries because it turns out
the story is very different for gauge
symmetries and I kind of hopefully this
discussion for global symmetries made
sense and you understood it you
understand that one direction in field
space is flat there for massless bosons
the perpendicular direction is curved
there for massive bosons once you get to
the gauge symmetries it's much harder to
actually
through the details in this way so I'm
not what I'm gonna do is tell you the
answer okay so for gauge symmetries well
you start with some massless bosons
right you start with not scalar bosons
but vector bosons the spin one particles
that are actually carrying the gauge
symmetry right the force bosons the
photons the gluons the gravitons or what
have you okay so you start with so pre
spontaneous symmetry breaking you might
have massless spin-1 bosons and maybe
you also have some massive scalars okay
so if we had a theory like this but it
was all pluses in the potential so there
was no spontaneous symmetry breaking the
minimum was just at zero you could have
some massive scalar fields that will
give you massive scalar bosons and they
could be coupled to some gauge
potentials right so to some so in this
case in this theory that we have right
now it's an Esso to symmetry so that's
the same as au 1 symmetry so we'd have
the equivalent of photons this would be
a kind of photon like theory and that
that those would be your massless spin-1
gauge bosons and then you have some
massive scalar bosons that's let's let's
say this is without so no spontaneous
symmetry breaking then you have with
spontaneous symmetry breaking what
happens is the colorful language that we
use is that the gauge bosons eat the
Goldstone bosons and get fat they get
massive okay so you get massive spin one
bosons
so in this case by the way let's like
stick with this theory without
spontaneous symmetry breaking what we
mean is the potential looks like this
you did not have spontaneous symmetry
breaking
so here's V of Phi Phi 1 Phi 2 and we're
imagining that it's plus Phi squared
plus 5 to the fourth okay so you have
guess what - can I move this yeah
oops no always forget what I can do oh
yeah like that I did it two massive
scalars one massless spin-1 boson if you
have an su s o 2 gauge Theory the photon
basically with spontaneous symmetry
breaking what you have is a massive spin
one boson and one massive scalar so this
is the case where the potential looks
like the Mexican hat very sloppily drawn
Mexican hat so the direction that is
along the flat part the vacuum manifold
is now eaten by the gauge boson and it
becomes massive so the point is another
way of saying this I I know I'm skipping
over a lot of things there's just too
much stuff going on here a massless
gauge boson well a massive mess let's
spin one boson that's saying I'm
glossing over one of the facts is that
except for gravity which is weird
all the gauge bosons the force carrying
particles have spin 1 we haven't even
talked about spin yet but you're just
gonna believe me for right now the
massless spin-1 boson has two degrees of
freedom and what does that mean well we
talked about degrees of freedom of
degrees of a degree of freedom is you
know how much information you need to
tell me to fully specify what's going on
so if I have one single scalar field
filling the universe I say one degree of
freedom if it's a real scalar field if
it's a complex scalar field or
it's too real scalar fields I have two
degrees of freedom a massless spin-1
boson is 2 degrees of freedom and
basically the way we think about that is
if you're moving so if this is the
momentum of the boson then it has spin
and it can either be spin this way
okay spinning right handed compared to
where you're moving or it can be
spinning this way those are the two
choices so it can be spinning right
handed or left handed right handed or
left handed circular polarization for
you classical electromagnetic fans out
there so the spin can be either along
the axis or opposed to the axis and
those are the only possibilities because
when the boson is massless it has to
move at the speed of light for a massive
spin one boson it doesn't have to move
at the speed of light so there are three
degrees of freedom and that's because
there is also a the particle is spinning
perpendicularly to the direction of
motion or I should say the direction of
motion is not even defined so if if I go
to the rest frame I could imagine it's
spinning this way spinning this way or
spinning this way you might say why
can't it spin that way well because this
is supposed to be symmetric around the
circle so spinning perpendicularly that
way is this the same no matter how I
oriented I know that's not completely
convincing us cuz we haven't talked
about spin yet but this is the true
thing the point is that with spontaneous
symmetry breaking in a gauge Theory you
don't get Goldstone bosons ever what you
get are massive gauge bosons so you know
or you you've sort of been glancingly
referred to this in the case of the
standard model right what do we have in
the standard model the standard model of
particle physics we know that it's based
on a symmetry su3 cross as
to cross you 1 and that symmetry is
spontaneously broken via the Higgs
mechanism down to su 3 cross u 1 now you
might think that what that is saying is
that su 2 is broken and the rest are
left unbroken it's not quite that simple
the su 3 that you get the strong
interactions su 3 is just instill
unbroken okay it's just left unaffected
by the Higgs boson but the Higgs boson
affects both su 2 and u 1 and it breaks
them both but it leaves this u 1
invariant okay so it leaves are you one
behind morally it's equivalent to just
breaking one su 2's worth of symmetry
but this is what actually happens in the
real world I want to be I want to be
telling you what actually happened so
we're not going to go through the
details but we're going to count degrees
of freedom that's that's that's
something we can do it's those numbers
are small they do not require a lot of
arithmetic Talent
so you're breaking su 2 cross u 1 down
to a single u 1 so it's kind of like the
U 1 just goes along for the ride it
really doesn't it's more complicated
let's pretend that it does okay so it's
like you're breaking su 2 to nothing
it's like you start with an su 2
symmetry gauge symmetry and you
completely break it okay so what is su 2
su 2 loops su 2 is almost again sort of
morally it is almost so3 it's a three
dimensional group okay and what that
means is therefore there are three gauge
bosons okay this is before symmetry
breaking happens so let's just say there
are three gauge bosons that's all we
will do but then you also have the Higgs
which is a complex doublet of scalars
this makes sense cuz it's su 2 right so
the Higgs let's call it H can be written
H 1 H 2 where both H 1 and H 2 are
complex
valued fields so this is one two three
four degrees of freedom because these
are complex valued fields every complex
scalar field has two degrees of freedom
and these are two complex valued fields
okay so four degrees of freedom overall
so it's again I can't really draw
four-dimensional space but it's kind of
like I can draw a three dimensional
space so if I had if I had a three
dimensional set of fields Phi 1 Phi 2
Phi 3 I don't I have four-dimensional
set of fields but I could imagine that
the potential would be minimized on a
two-dimensional sphere right that would
be the equivalent this would be three
dimensional Mexican hat and so the
vacuum manifold would be these points on
this sphere and I would have a number of
degrees of freedom they'll be along the
sphere okay and those would all be
Goldstone bosons in the global symmetry
breaking case and this is not a very
representation so I'm only able to draw
three of them but the point is these
four Higgs degrees of freedom DF degrees
of freedom after spontaneous symmetry
breaking go to one massive scalar boson
plus three massive gauge bosons so if
the symmetry were global rather than a
gauge symmetry there would be three
Goldstone bosons from the spontaneous
breaking of the Higgs by the Higgs of
this symmetry there'd be three
directions you could move the field that
would keep it in its vacuum manifold
this by the way is why there are no so I
don't know where to where to draw this
let me just say it in words this is why
there are no cosmic strings or mono
poles or domain walls in the standard
model of particle physics because the
vacuum manifold is a three sphere a
three-dimensional sphere that's why you
get three massive gauge bosons three
bosons three what we say would be
Goldstone bosons if they hadn't been
eaten by the gauge bosons and a three
sphere has no PI 1 or PI 2 or PI 0 no
non-trivial first second or zeroth
fundamental group so no strings mono
poles or domain walls there you go sorry
about that but anyway this is what you
actually have in the standard model of
particle physics these should be
familiar one massive scalar boson we
call it the Higgs boson that is what we
discovered at the Large Hadron Collider
in 2012 three massive gauge bosons which
we call the plus W particle the minus W
particle and the neutral Z particle the
Z naught ok these are three gauge bosons
that were massless before symmetry
breaking they ate up the Higgs boson and
they got backed and this is why the weak
interactions are short-range because
this these fields that carry the weak
interactions are massive if you go way
back up to this equation of motion that
we had right here for massive scalars
you could say well let's change the
right-hand side by adding a source okay
by adding some particle that creates
that the couples to this v field and
what you find is this sum I got wrong
last time what you find is a u Kawa
potential so the potential for this I'll
just write it in a different color so
the the the field value what what could
what can we say here if we if we plot as
a function of distance from some source
the value of Phi I'm using the word
potential in two different senses here
that's why I'm hesitating but it goes
down exponentially okay it goes e to the
minus M times R with this value of M
right there okay I said that the force
went like e to minus M R but that's not
right the force is the derivative of
this field value so it actually goes as
e to the minus M R over R just to be
very very careful there you go the point
is that this fades away very very
quickly as R gets large compared to the
inverse mask
Compton wavelength of the particle so
because the Compton wavelength is 1 over
the mass of a particle so when you have
these massive gauge bosons with these
the masses are very roughly 100 GeV it's
more like 85 and 90 or something like
that but still over the order 100 GeV
that's a very big number the Compton
wavelength is a very small number the
range over which the weak nuclear force
is noticeable is very very tiny that's
one of the reasons why neutrinos can
just pass through your body all the time
the tree nose can pass through the earth
all the time because neutrinos don't
feel the strong nuclear force they don't
feel the electromagnetic force they're
neutral they do feel the weak force but
the weak force is really weak yet we get
really really close to something before
you feel the weakened Equipe force and
this is why
okay so I'm not sure how convincing that
whole discussion was but the point is
this is actually so I'd need I haven't
even gotten to how electrons get mass
yet right a lot of people you'll hear
people say that the Higgs mechanism was
invented to give masses to the electrons
with the quarks or whatever which is
completely false
no one knew certain yo Higgs and brown
on glare and the others who were
thinking about these ideas in the early
1960s they had no idea that you could
use the Higgs to give masses to fermions
electrons and quarks and things like
that they thought that you could spun
they what they cared about which was
true is that you could spontaneously
break a gauge theory and make it go from
being long-range to being short-range
okay and the reason why they cared about
that is because they weren't even
thinking about the weak interactions
their thing about the strong
interactions they didn't know about QCD
they didn't know about asymptotic
freedom or confinement or quarks or any
of those things what they knew was it
was it seemed like an attractive idea to
make the strong interactions a gauge
theory but gauge theories gave one over
R squared forces and the strong
interactions were a short-range that's
why they invented the Higgs mechanism
they thought that the strong
interactions would be governed by a
theory like this and that's why it was
short-range
didn't work out that way because nature
is very complicated and tricky but
anyway this is the explanation for why
the gauge bosons in the standard model
have a mass it's because the Higgs
mechanism gives it to them they've eaten
up the Goldstone boson so this is
supposed to explain both why there are
no Goldstone bosons and why there are
massive vector spin 1 bosons in the
standard model ok so what about the
electrons why do they get their
electrons etc in the standard model what
does the Higgs boson have to do with
them getting mass again I'm gonna be a
little bit technical which means in this
case sketchy so usually people say
they're being technical they're gonna
flood you with details what I mean is
I'm hiding the details from you but just
saying words that are true and you'll
have to go fill them in so this is you
know again Higgs and brown on glare who
should the Nobel Prize for this also
Guralnik Hagen and kibble wrote
important papers about this Phil
Anderson wrote important papers about
this Nambu had thoughts about it at tuff
Ted thought about it mostly in the 60s
they were thing about the strong
interactions it was Steven Weinberg in
the late 60s who came up who wrote this
charming paper very short paper and the
title is just a model of leptons and he
was trying to explain different features
of the leptons and one of the features
of the leptons like electrons cuz they
violate parity ok they act differently
there are right-handed leptons and
left-handed leptons and they seem to
behave differently very roughly speaking
the weak interactions tend to interact
with the left-handed leptons but not the
right-handed leptons they act with
left-handed particles and right-handed
the anti particles okay but right-handed
particles and left-handed anti particles
are just not doing anything in the weak
interactions and so Weinberg was trying
to understand this and what you would
guess what if you were clever enough to
know the underlying particle physics
would you would guess is left-handed
electrons have a gauge symmetry of some
sort right as we now know it's an su 2
gauge symmetry and right-handed
electrons don't so you can just say that
that would
explained how electrons could have this
interaction with the weak interactions
but the problem is the mass term for an
ordinary electron if you're Paul Dirac
and you're writing down the Dirac
equation and you think about the mass
term for the electron I said that you
know all mass terms are field squared
right Phi squared or gamma squared for
the photon or whatever but for fermions
it's a little bit trickier it's still
field squared but it's actually the
right-handed field times the left-handed
field very roughly speaking okay so the
mass term actually looks like psy bar
sigh if psy is the field let's call this
cyi so this is the electron field or
this is what you would guess it looks
like mass times that it's actually only
mass to the first power not the second
power because fermions are weird and
different it's but different in the
scalar fields but okay here you go
and it turns out when you this bar is
like a complex conjugation kind of
operation but it also flips right-handed
with left-handed so if you have a
symmetry that has an effect on the
left-handed field but not the
right-handed field so this is again
morally it's not exactly right this is
kind of like psy right x side left okay
not exactly right but okay close enough
if psy left has a gauge symmetry and psy
right doesn't which is what the data
seems to imply in the weak interactions
then you can't write down this term so
this was a known problem like if you
have a symmetry that it effects
left-handed particles differently than
right-handed particles then you're not
going to be able to have a mass for any
of those particles not just the gauge
bosons but even the fermions that are
related to those particles so what
Weinberg realized was that what you
could do is with the Higgs boson
remember we have this doublet here right
capital H h1 h2 so what you could do is
you could write down the right-handed
electron so psy electron right which is
just a single thing all by its
you could multiply it by H which is this
doublet of Higgs fields and then you
have a doublet of electron and psy II
know and the neutrino psy knew L so in
other words what Weinberg says is maybe
deep down in the bowels of the Standard
Model of particle physics there is a
symmetry relating electrons to neutrinos
they're a doublet under an su 2 symmetry
the right the left-handed ones the
right-handed ones don't have that
symmetry they're just single all by
themselves and but what you can do is
you can make a interaction term not a
mass term but an interaction term with
the Higgs boson and then what happens is
for spontaneous symmetry breaking let's
write it this way under spontaneous
symmetry breaking the Higgs field which
is a dynamical feel - can fluctuate gets
the form some fixed value V and then 0
plus fluctuations so this is the sort of
equation way of saying that you know the
field in its Mexican hat sits there at
some value V ok so the first component
of the higgs field takes the value v the
second component is just zero and what
that means is that this term here starts
looking like sy e r v x sy er x sy e L
which is just the mass term for the
electron and there is no corresponding
term for the neutrino and that's why
neutrinos are massless in the simplest
versions of the standard model because
there's no right-handed neutrino to do
anything quarks are more complicated but
anyway everything is more complicated
this is why I'm not doing a whole video
on the standard model but the point is
Weinberg realized that the Higgs
mechanism which was invented to solve
the strong interactions could be applied
to the weak interactions and would
explain not only why the weak
interactions were short-range but also
how you could have a gauge theory that
affected left-handed particles but not
right-handed
articles and yet still had those
particles be massive through the genius
of spontaneous symmetry breaking so this
was not the original reason reason why
the Higgs boson was invented but roughly
speaking this existence of the Higgs
vacuum expectation value the Higgs field
has a nonzero value out there in space
the electrons are able to react against
that value of the higgs boson in empty
space and thereby get a mass it's a
completely separate mechanism from how
the gauge bosons get a mass but it is
nevertheless true at the end of the day
that the Higgs mechanism gives a mass to
both the gauge bosons W plus W minus and
Z of the weak interactions and the
fermions of the weak interactions the
electrons the muons a Tau and all the
quarks okay I understand that there's
too many details being glossed over to
really get that but I wanted to say a
bunch of true things that by following
all these videos you are in a position
to at least kind of understand in a way
that you know I wrote a whole book about
the Higgs boson and the standard model
particle at the end of the universe and
I couldn't quite explain things in this
much detail there so you get more than
they would get okay anyway lesson how
mass comes in the standard model from
the Higgs boson and as we said before
protons and neutrons get mass from a
completely different mechanism but the
quarks inside them do get mass from the
Higgs mechanism exactly like this the
other thing I wanted to say about the
standard model is people you know I
don't know what street corners you
people are spending time on but I made a
plot something like this with energy and
I plotted the running of the coupling
constants right
the you know as you go to higher and
higher energies the strong interactions
get weaker and weaker
that's called asymptotic freedom
asymptotically as you go to high
energies the particles just become free
they are not interacting though
interactions get weak so whereas for
electromagnetism the interactions
actually get stronger so in the standard
model s oops
su3 cross su 2 cross 1 in the standard
model there are 3 different coupling
constants one for you 1 you're tempted
to say it's electromagnetism but it's
not remember in the standard model the
actual u1 that you get for
electromagnetism is not the u1 you
started with when you say yes you to
question because if there's a admixture
of s u2 and u1 so this is actually you
want hyper-charged I'm writing that very
tiny so no one can read it because I'm
not telling what the details are but
just trying to get it right just trying
to say true things so this is the u1
hyper-charged and it has a coupling
constant alpha 1 and there's a coupling
constant for the SU 3 bit alpha 3 and
there's also a coupling constant for the
SU 2 bit alpha 2 okay and what you see
is if alpha 2 and alpha 3 are going down
and alpha 1 is going up maybe they all
meet at some high energy scale right
maybe they're converging on each other
and they can somehow meet each other
this is not an original idea this idea
actually Stephen Weinberg and others
talked about this in the early 70s and
this was put to good use by Howard
George I and Sheldon Glashow in the mid
70s when they invented grand unification
so this is the idea that at this energy
scale near where they meet grand
unification occurs this idea from the
seventies it may or may not be true but
if you have all the gauge groups of the
standard model su 3 su 2 cross u 1 as
subgroups of some bigger group you might
imagine that bigger group has a single
coupling constant so it only is one
value but then it's spontaneously is
breaking the symmetry there's some
fields they're called cleverly x and y
bosons that break the symmetry of some
high energy so this energy is about 10
to the very roughly 16 GeV remember the
Higgs boson is down at 10 to the 2 GeV
and electrons and quarks or even lighter
than that so there's a very high energy
scale the Planck scale is 10 to the 18
GeV so it's pretty close to the
playing scale and the scene in the
seventies eighties like a good idea
right like you know the coupling
constants would run they would unify and
not only will they meet but we will
literally unify them by saying that s u3
s e2 costs you one are all subgroups of
some bigger group like SU five or s o
ten or six there's different famous
groups that people tried to use so
without really trying to but you know
without not trying to either the way
that I drew it here they don't quite
meet and it turns out that as we got
better and better data you know these
these curves the way that alpha 1 alpha
2 alpha 3 change with energy depends on
not only their values at low energies
and not only the gauge groups therein
but also things like what particles they
couple to the masses of those particles
and things like that you know the
interaction strains with the Higgs stuff
like that so there's a bunch of
parameters that you measure to calculate
these curves and in the 70s and 80s we
had measured them not so well so to the
error bars that we knew then these
curves met at some high energy once the
90s rolled around we had measured these
curves well enough that they no longer
met like the precision became good and
we realized they're not actually
intersecting so this was this you know
there but turns out there's two
attitudes you can take it with that one
is okay grand unification is wrong by
the way grainy invocation also predicts
proton decay and you haven't measured
that so maybe granny vacation is just
wrong but the other possibility is that
there are more particles in between you
know here's what we actually observe
down here like Large Hadron Collider
okay there's a lot of room up here in
between the Large Hadron Collider and
the grand unification scale by the way
also a grand unification scale that
might be the scale at which something
like inflation happens in cosmology so
you know there's a lot of good happy
feelings warm fuzzy feelings about grand
unification but it didn't it didn't work
in the most naive way and so maybe one
idea is that there are new particles in
between the energies we've seen and the
granny's vacation scale that affect how
these different curves meet so
one simple idea is supersymmetry so what
you can do is if you put supersymmetry
at some intermediate energy scale then
you can make the curves tilt a little
bit so you get something like this and
this this and now they actually do all
meet or they would meet if I was a more
accurate crafts person so there was this
big belief in the 90s and you know some
people still believe it today that if
supersymmetry exists at energies
slightly higher than what we were able
to observe it can salvage the dream of
grand unification and without it or
without something equivalent to mess
with these curves it's harder to see
that happening it's not impossible
nothing's ever impossible particle
physicists are very clever and inventing
models you notice some of the romance
goes out of it though because if you
have three lines in a plane and they
happen to meet at one point that is a
non-generic thing and that's kind of
impressive like two lines will almost
always meet somewhere but three lines
intersecting at the same point is a
special thing here you have three lines
but also a free parameter you can move
where you want the supersymmetry scale
to be so it becomes much less impressive
that there is unification at all and
also we haven't found any supersymmetric
particles maybe we'll find them tomorrow
we haven't found them yet so honestly
people don't know what to think about
this people don't know is their grand
unification is there supersymmetry any
of these things these were very
theoretically attractive ideas from the
70s and 80s there's no empirical
evidence for them yet and and there's
been anti empirical evidence there you
know there's things we could have found
easily so as good Bayesian z-- our idea
our our credence that these ideas were
correct is lower now than it was 20
years ago and by the way I'm this is all
quantum field theory we haven't
mentioned a super string theory yet but
there was in super string theory
string theory this is old-fashioned
string theory so old-fashioned string
theory there were five string theories
and there was one that was especially
popular
to be the real world and that was the e8
cross e eight heterotic string and e 8
cross e eight were the gauge groups so
we've talked about s o n gauge groups as
you and gauge groups there are other
ones or others other continuous groups
lis groups that would be candidates for
being gauge groups of something or
another and there's a set of exceptional
gauge groups special ones that sort of
don't fit in into that other
classifications and ei tis one of the
best ones it's one of the you know most
impressive gauge groups and the string
theorists didn't put it in the string
theorists went through and said what
could possibly be the gauge groups of
string theory and they literally only
found five answers okay and E 8 cross e
eight was one of them
and one of the nice things about that
one of the reasons why that was thought
to be very promising is that there is a
very natural symmetry breaking pattern
where you go from e 8 cross e 8 and you
break one of them entirely so you just
get EI t' and that breaks naturally down
to what is called e6 I'm not explaining
these at all I'm telling you this is
true an e6 breaks down to su 5 which can
break very naturally down to su 3 cross
su 2 cross u 1 and sometimes instead of
su 5 is that so 10 or something like
that but this is so it was all so even
though not necessary for grand
unification it was possible to fit grand
unification into the scheme of super
string theory very very easily easily
I said old-fashioned string theory
because in the early I guess the mid-90s
following Jo polchinski ed Witten and
others showed that in fact there's only
one string theory in some sense because
what we felt were five different string
theories and also there's another one 11
dimensional supergravity
these are all just different limiting
cases of the single underlying theory
that is now called m-theory but even
though that's an advanced now we know
that these are all related to each other
we know very little about what M theory
is and you've heard the story probably
about how there's differ
ways to compactify m-theory to get the
world and there might be 10 to the 500
different ways and so rather than having
five different candidates we have 10 to
the 500 different candidates for
constructing the real world out of
string theory and that's a lot harder
task so we don't know quite what to do
with that
all right we've already gone on an hour
here and I discussed the most important
things okay I did discuss those but let
me let me just do a couple of other
things very quickly before going away so
electromagnetic gauge invariance I want
it so we talked about sorry should not
talk and right same time magnetic gauge
invariance so I said that this is a u 1
gauge Theory electromagnetism is U 1
gauge theory and in particular you have
something like the electron field sigh e
goes to e to the I theta which is a
function of X because it's a gauge
Theory cyi we're ignoring spin and su 2
doublets and all that complicated stuff
but this is the basic thing that happens
this is the gauge invariance of
electromagnetism at every point you take
the electromagnetic field and you rotate
it by a complex phase that can be
different at every point in space and so
there were two very very good questions
relating this thing that I told you two
things you learned somewhere else okay
so what about quantum mechanics you know
in quantum mechanics you have a wave
function and that's also capital psy
just to distinguish it from the electron
field capital psy is a complex number
and I can imagine taking capital psy and
multiplying it by some phase call it e
to the I alpha may be alpha is not good
now health is fine it's not the
fine-structure constant just some number
alpha times sign and we know the
probability is size squared and that
just goes to size squared so this is an
invariance that is
the probability of getting a certain
outcome in quantum mechanics is
unchanged if I multiply the wavefunction
by e to the I alpha right because it
doesn't change the square so doesn't
that is that related is that the same
thing is it similar and you know the
short answer is no they're not the same
thing they're not related but there's a
longer answer he knew there was going to
be right so the quantum mechanical wave
function remember is a vector in Hilbert
space if you have two particles for
example well let me say it this way if
you have a single particle in good old
nonrelativistic Schrodinger style
quantum mechanics then the wave function
sy is a function of position and time
also but it's a function of the position
of that particle okay but if you have
two particles then the wave function is
a function of two copies of space x1 and
x2 right and if you have 10 to the 80th
particles like you have in the universe
then the wave function is a function of
3 times 10 to the 80th different
coordinates three dimensions of space 10
to the 80th particles okay
whereas this sigh E is a function of X
that's it because it's a field it's a
classical field it is not a wave
function so this thing when I say you
know you multiply for the u 1 gauge
Theory then you multiply by e to the I
theta X that's the same X as where psy
is for every value of x psy has a value
and the gauge parameter has a value okay
here in the quantum mechanical wave
function there's no equivalent of that
there's no when you say sigh at what
point it's you know every different
particle this is describing has
different locations in space so there's
just no map onto that so there's no
parameter this this alpha here is not a
function of space in any simple way it's
just once and for all you can just
multiply the whole wave function by a
complex phase and everything is
invariant so there's a similar structure
but it's not the same thing okay the
invariance of the quantum mechanical
wave function under a single phase
rotation is not the origin of the gauge
invariance of electromagnetism however
having said that there is a relationship
I'm not going to go into it in detail
but if you go through the details of
starting with the quantum field theory
wavefunction and then you reduce it to
the situation where you just have a
single particle electron and then you
look at the equations of motion for that
particle you can turn it into a
Schrodinger like equation for the wave
function that looks like the wave
equation for the electron field it's you
know the Dirac equation gets involved
and it's very complicated so I'm just
letting you know again if you if you dig
into this very deeply you will see there
is a relationship but conceptually
they're very different the relationship
is not central to at what we're talking
about here the phase invariants of the
quantum mechanical wave function is a
different thing than gauge invariants
the other question very closely related
is what about classical what do you
might call Maxwell electromagnetism so
if you've taken an electromagnetism
class classical electromagnetism there
is something called gauge invariance but
it doesn't look anything at all like
this it looks very different so in what
you have in Maxwell electromagnetism is
you know you have the electric field E
of X and you have the magnetic field B
of X and these are the things you know
the fundamental dynamical variables
Maxwell's equations tell you how these
couple two electric charges and magnetic
fields are created by moving charges in
that whole bit but what do you figure
out what what someone tells you or you
figure out is that you can have a vector
field a called the vector potential so I
should write this as a function of X
just like a and B and a scalar field
capital Phi of X called the scalar
potential and from these four numbers so
a is a vector so there's three numbers
right a X a Y Z Phi is a single number
single function so there's one number
there from these four vectors you can
derive what E and B are and since I
don't prepare for these videos I'm not
going to get the
formula is exactly right I know formulas
that are correct but they're like fancy
four-dimensional formulas these the
old-fashioned formulas I forget but
basically E is like - the the
derivatives with respect to space of
capital Phi the X plus the derivative
expected time of a so there's three
numbers on each side good that matches
and B is what we call I'm just gonna
have to use some vector notation here
vector calculus here the curl of a which
is a fancy way of saying that the x
equals the derivative of a Y with
respect to Z minus the derivative of a Z
with respect to Y and other permutations
okay so you don't have to remember any
of these I'm not trying to explain these
level of detail that you would actually
understand I'm just trying to tell you
that they're there but the point is
there's gauge invariance here so I could
always in Maxwell's theory I could just
work with E and B I can just work with
the electric and magnetic fields but it
was even Maxwell knew that you could
also rewrite them in a somewhat simpler
way in terms of a and Phi so a and B you
might think there's three components of
e three components of B so there's six
numbers six functions right but this
little bit of prestidigitation shows you
there's really only four functions that
you need to derive what both a and B are
doing so they're not independent from
each other and there is gauge invariance
here so the gauge invariance in this
case roughly looks like you take a and
you send it to a plus the derivative I
don't know what the best notation use
here is the notation everyone actually
uses is this grad lambda of X so grad
lambda this is a funny notation with the
upside-down triangle which means a
vector and the components of the vector
are d lambda d
xD lambda oops D lambda T Y and D lambda
D Z so the derivatives they should
actually be partial derivatives if
you're being careful but the derivatives
of this function lambda in the different
directions and there's another thing for
Phi it also changes so this is gauge
invariance this is a change in the
vector potential at every point due to
this function lambda that leaves all the
equations in Merrion you can go through
you can check that E and B don't change
when you do this particular
transformation so this is what we call
gauge invariance in classical
electromagnetism does it have to do with
the what I'm telling you is do you wanna
gauge transformation yeah what it has to
do is lambda is the same as theta that
is to say ie when you send a goes to a
plus the gradient as its called gradient
of lambda you send sigh e to e to the I
lambda so I eat that's what it is
so again in an ordinary non field theory
Maxwell electromagnetism you don't need
to worry about this because just have
particles with charge okay and the
particles with charge don't change under
gauge invariants at all but once you go
to field theory and you want a couple
everything together in a simple way this
is what you have to do you have to
actually let both the gauge field and
the matter field in this case the
electron change under a gauge
transformation but all I'm telling you
here is that they really are the same
gauge transformation the gauge
transformations I'm telling you about
are the same ones that we told you about
that you were told about in your
electromagnetism course and there's more
to do with this okay so from all this
knowledge you can figure out you know
how you can take the fields and combine
them together to get things that are
invariant under gauge transformations
and that's what you need in the
Lagrangian the Lagrangian s'ti that
defines the theory so I mean maybe one
more thing maybe one more thing I gotta
tell you okay
maybe two more things well one is very
quick let me just say it in words people
people wanted a little bit more clarity
on this claim that if you have a local
symmetry so let's say you have quarks
red green and blue and you want to
compare them at two different points in
space so you should know how to
transport and the claim was if you
wanted to say there was a symmetry that
let you rotate the quarks independently
at every point in space then in order to
compare them you need a connection field
and that's literally what a is here this
is this is why the photon field is
usually not called gamma in particle
physics it's usually called a because of
Maxwell's electromagnetism this is the
field that you quantize in field theory
for electromagnetism
it's a in fact what you do is sorry I
tell you more than you want to know the
vector the four vector potential because
of special relativity is a mu which is
what we called Phi and then what we
called a so a four dimensional vector
because it's relativity so space-time is
four dimensional this is the thing that
gives you the photon when you quantize
it and so people said well you know what
do you mean that this demand of a
symmetry causes you to have a connection
field in some way and you know so let me
just confess that's sloppy language
that's a language that we always use
when we talk about these things the the
more strictly correct thing to say is
you have a connection field the world
has one okay it's not that anything
forces you to do it the way to think
about it is if you wanted in order to
have a gauge symmetry a local symmetry
symmetry that is allowing you to do
symmetry transformations independently
at different points in space then you
need a connection you need a connection
field otherwise you have no way of
comparing what's going on at different
points in space now you don't need to
say that connection field is dynamical
you could imagine a theory in which the
gauge field is just given by God it's
just fixed here it is it's not
fluctuating it's not
changing overtime it's not responding to
what's going on elsewhere but it's still
there and in case this sounds crazy to
you there's a theory just like that it's
called special relativity okay in
general relativity where you have
gravity is dynamical and fluctuating the
connection field changes from place to
place it has dynamics Einstein's
equation is what gives it to it but in
special relativity there's still
space-time there's still a way to
compare vectors at different points in
space-time in other words there is a
connection but the connection is just
given it's just fixed and it's flat the
curvature of it is zero so there's no
you know there's no necessity that comes
along with having these fields you know
you you do experiments ultimately when
you want to say like people ask well why
is it su three across su 2 cross u one
do you do the experiments you do
particle physics and you say that's
what's needed to fit the data right and
they say like well if you have three
quarks how do you know there's three
different if there's three quarks and a
proton how do you know three different
colors well as we will see there's
something called the Pauli exclusion
principle two fermions like quarks
cannot be in exactly the same state but
it turns out that the two up quarks
let's say in a proton basically are in
the same state how is that possible well
one of them is right of one of them is
blue or anyway they're two different
colors so they're not really in the same
state so we know that we need these
different colors in order to make sense
of what's goes on a proton so all this
is driven by data all of this is driven
by trying to understand the actual data
that's the only real reason we know that
these fields exist because you need them
to fit the data and the final thing is
let me say again a little bit more
detail than you want but one more little
connection between gauge fields and
curvature remember so we said that if
you have a gauge field you can parallel
transport comparable transport vectors
in some generalized sense like a quark
with its colors I'll take a little
internal vector and parallel transport
lets you define the curvature of that
gauge field and we talked about the
Riemann tensor
and depending on whether you watch the
Q&A video one way of writing the Riemann
tensor is are Rho lambda mu nu but it's
a map from three vectors V 1 V 2 V 3 to
a fourth vector V 4 and the map is this
little thing I'm not going to go through
all the details but V 1 V 2 backwards
minus V 1 minus V 2 and then if you have
V 3 it gets changed by an amount before
okay so that's what the map is and so
you might say so there's two questions
here can you have there's a lot of
questions here sorry can you have zero
curvature can you have a connection
without curvature can you set the
connection which is flat the answer is
absolutely yes
and that would be special relativity for
example in space-time so the connection
this is the Riemann tensor what I didn't
tell you is that there's something
called the connection I told you there
was something called the connection but
I didn't tell you the formula or the
symbols the connection looks like this
gamma lambda mu nu okay and this is
roughly what tells you so the real
intention tensor tells you how does a
single vector rotate a little bit when
you go around a loop defined by two
vectors roughly the connection is saying
if I just have a single direction that
I'm moving in okay
the one and then I have a vector that I
am moving the two and I move it a little
bit it sort of changed infinitesimally
okay compared to where it was and that's
v3 so that's why there are three indices
on the connection and the way so this
connection tells you how to transport in
one direction but that just depends a
lot near the details the actual
equations depend a lot on what your
coordinates are and what direction
you're moving in etc whereas the Riemann
tensor is what we would call gauge
invariant it is independent of your
coordinates or anything like that it's a
much better defined thing and to get to
the question that was being asked there
are exactly
equivalent structures in the gauge
theories for internal symmetries like su
3 costs su 2 cross u 1 so for su 3
instead of the connection sadly we still
use the letter A
whether it's su 3 or su 2 or anything we
would write a mu a B why do we use
different letters why is you know the
connect so for the Riemann tensor and
the space-time connection the reason why
gravity and space-time are harder or
more interesting is because it's only
space-time there's only vectors that
literally point in directions so the
question what about the vector you're
moving and the question what direction
are you moving it in our questions being
asked relative to the same space namely
space-time here when you have an su 3
connection then you're still taking a
direction in space-time V 1 okay but
you're saying I'm moving a quark field
so let me draw in a different color Q
and that gets moved to here under
parallel transport so it changed a
little bit and I when asked by how much
does the quark field change so these
indices a and B are quark indices or
really s u3 indices and so now unlike in
the Riemann tensor and space-time case
where all indices are in the same
direction or in the same space up down
left right forward backward past future
here there's indices in color space
which are a and B and an index in
space-time which is the direction you're
parallel transporting it and there is
curvature su3 curvature and roughly
speaking we call that capital G I
shouldn't call it capital G let me call
it capital F mu nu a B and yeah it's
complicated sorry but I got to tell you
what it is I started so I shouldn't stop
it
is the derivative in the mewed erection
of a new a B minus the derivative in the
new direction of a mu a B minus or plus
on them you're going to get it right a I
don't having a this right a mu a see a
new C B and call that plus and then
minus a new C who something like that
this is a very close approximation of
the true thing anyway the point is
there's an absolute parallelism from the
connection in space-time you can
construct the Riemann tensor from the
connection in the gauge Theory su3
construct this curvature tensor and from
this curvature tensor you're going to
make the equations of motion for the
gauge field so for electromagnetism for
example I forget I think I might have
said this already for electromagnetism F
mu nu doesn't need to have any indices
because it's just a single complex
number that is being moved around
there's no indices it's not like su 2 or
su 3 where there's two or three
different directions there's one
direction so FME doesn't need any
indices for E&M just a u 1 gauge field
and it all circles back this is there
are zeros it's a four by four matrix
zeros on the diagonal how do you know
that because if you look closely this
formula I wrote down its anti-symmetric
in mu and nu so whatever the value of f
mu nu is for one value of mu and nu when
I switch mu and nu it better be minus
that so this is F 0 0 F 1 1 etc so if I
switch 0 and 0 I get 0 and 0 so the
number that is equal to minus itself is
0 so all these diagonal elements are
exactly 0 okay and the top line here I
never get the minus signs here right but
this is the electric field e x ey ez
minus ax
- ey - easy and these other three empty
slots the magnetic field B Z minus B X B
Y minus B nope I didn't get that right
did I
I mean how I had a good chance of
getting it right just didn't quite see
that's B Y this is B X I'm not getting
the signs right but you want to get the
indices right this is minus B X this is
B Y this is minus BC anyway way more
detail than you need way more detailed
you can possibly follow all this is to
say that the good old fashioned way of
doing electromagnetism that Maxwell
would have recognized is still here
it's still there in this fancy Dancy
language of connections and gauge fields
and things like that they're all related
to each other and you know I'm not
giving you enough information to
understand all these indices and but
it's actually pretty understandable like
it's way easier than quantum mechanics
to be honest so if you can find a good
book on classical gauge Theory I'm not
sure if there is one but I think there
Valarie Rubik off wrote a book it's a
big hard book but it's called classical
gauge Theory that's one but anyway
Gabe's theories are worth learning about
they're really interesting there's a lot
going on I am many many more things that
I could say but you know ARS longa vita
brevis we have other things to do so
thanks for sitting around with this one
this was a long complicated Q&A video
but it's worth it this is important
stuff this is how the real world works